but this new variant is of huge
international concern
the world health organization has called
a special meeting this morning and that
meeting is taking place right now
i want to update the house on what we
know so far why we're concerned and the
action that we are taking
although i must stress
that this is a fast-moving situation and
there remains a high degree of
uncertainty
the sequence of this variant currently
called b11529
was first uploaded by hong kong from a
case of someone traveling from south
africa
the uk was the first country to identify
the potential threat of this new variant
and to alert international partners
further cases have been identified in
south africa
and in botswana and it is highly likely
that it is now spread to other countries
yesterday the south african government
held a press conference where they
provided an update on what they know so
far
i want to put on record my thanks to
south africa not only for their rigorous
scientific response but the openness and
transparency with which they have acted
much as we did here in the united
kingdom when we first detected what is
now known as the alpha variant
madam deputy speaker
we are concerned that this new variant
may pose substantial risk to public
health
the variant has an unusually large
number of mutations
yesterday the uk health security agency
classified
b11529 as a new variant under
investigation
and the variant technical group has
designated it as a variant under
investigation with very high priority
it's the only variant with this
designation making it higher priority
than beta
it shares many of the features of alpha
beta and delta variance
early indications show
this variant may be more transmissible
than the delta variant
and current vaccines may be less
effective against it
it may also impact the effectiveness of
one of our major treatments ronald reef
madam deputy speaker
we're also worried about the rising
cases in countries in southern africa
especially as these populations should
have significant natural immunity
in south africa in particular
there has been exponential growth with
cases increasing four-fold over the last
two weeks
in gaoteng province which includes
johannesburg and pretoria some eighty
percent of cases
when tested with a pcr test have shown
something that is known as the s gene
drop out
which we associate with this variant
so while we don't know yet definitively
whether the exponential growth in south
africa is directly associated with this
new variant
this pcr test analysis does indicate
that there could be many more cases of
this new variant than just those that
have been sequenced so far
so madam deputy speaker
even as we continue to learn more about
this new variant
one of the lessons of this pandemic has
been that we must move quickly and at
the earliest possible moment
the uk remains in a strong position
we've made tremendous gains as a result
of the decisions that we took over the
summer and the initial success of our
booster program
but we're heading into winter
and our booster program is still ongoing
so we must act with caution
so we're taking the following steps
yesterday i announced that from midday
today we're placing cis countries in
southern africa on the travel red list
these countries are south africa
botswana le cetu
namibia and zimbabwe
anyone who is not a uk or irish resident
who has been in one of these countries
in the last 10 days will be denied entry
into england uk and irish residents
arriving from these countries from 4 am
on sunday will enter hotel quarantine
anyone arriving before
then before those dates should take pcr
tests on day two and day eight
even if they are vaccinated and isolate
at home
along with the rest of their household
if you've arrived from any of these
countries in the last 10 days nhs test
and trace will be contacting you and
asking you to take pcr tests
but please do not wait to be contacted
you should take pcr tests
right away
we've been working closely with the
devolved administrations on this and
they will be aligning their response
in recent hours israel has also taken
similar precautions
madam deputy speaker i wish to stress
that we're working quickly and we're
working with a high degree of
uncertainty
we are continuing to make assessments
including about those countries with
strong travel links to south africa
and we are working with our
international partners
including south africa and the european
union to ensure an aligned response
but this variant is a reminder for all
of us that this pandemic is far from
over
we must continue to act with caution and
do all we can to keep this virus at bay
including
once you are eligible
getting your booster shot
we've already given over 16 million
booster shots the booster jab was
already important before we knew about
this variant but now
it could not be more important
so please if you are eligible get your
booster shot do not delay
madam deputy speaker we've made great
progress against this virus progress
that we are determined to hold on to
this government will continue to do
whatever is necessary to keep us safe
and we've all got our part to play i
commend this statement to the house